bonsoir à toutes et à tous je suis ravi
d'être là impressionné même je vis
depuis quelques mois à madrid donc un
peu plus loin
oui de cette belle normandie je vis à
madrid
et là bas je prends des cours d'espagnol
parce que évidemment je ne parle pas la
langue de mon pays d'accueil ce serait
bien trop facile donc je prends des
cours d'espagnol et à l'occasion de ses
coûts j'ai eu l'occasion de discuter
avec des personnes d'horizons très
différents dans ce cours il y a des
indiennes des brésiliennes un kazakh un
portugais un sénégalais et moi et à
l'occasion d'une discussion avec eux je
me suis rendu compte que vraiment on
nous envie à nous français
cette école qui formeraient un esprit
critique
alors en fait finalement moi je ne
mesure pas vraiment à quel point c'est
vrai parce que en regardant en arrière
mon parcours d'écolière puis deux
lycéennes puis d'étudiantes la
conscience de la nécessité
cette impérieuse des nécessités d'un
esprit critique mais venu vraiment sur
le tard alors je vais vous raconter
cette rencontre
mais avant cela je voudrais vous
expliquer pourquoi je suis là je n'ai
clairement pas une définition absolue de
l'esprit critique
je ne suis pas non plus une experte mais
par contre ce que j'ai envie de partager
avec vous c'est ma petite recette
personnelle autour de cet esprit
critique parce que suite à cette
rencontre dont je vais vous parler et
bien l'esprit critique est devenue une
boussole pour mon existence et j'ai
envie de vous parler des ingrédients qui
viennent le nourrir alors je reprend le
fil de mon histoire
nous revenons au siècle dernier fin de
siècle
je viens d'avoir mon bac 1 bac
littéraire et je n'ai pas vraiment de
projet donc je décide d'aller à la fac
de droit parce que c'est tout près de
chez moi
et puis le droit je savais que ça
servirait bien tôt ou tard l'histoire
commence et devient intéressante en
cours de relations internationales
nous sommes dans un amphi à
mont-saint-aignan pas très loin d'ici et
le professeur lens à l'amphithéâtre qui
était plus ou moins attentif il vous
faut muscler votre culture générale
lisez le monde diplomatique
alors moi étudiante obéissante
je deviens une lectrice assidue du monde
diplomatique
je lis j'apprends je crois à prendre en
tout cas c'est une petite musique
récurrentes
je lis tous les to les toutes les
sorties du journal et puis un jour
anodin une discussion anodine un discute
avec des amis des connaissances on
commence à parler du moyen-orient et là
vraiment un moment marquant dans ma vie
je prends la parole et c'est comme une
expérience quasiment paranormal puisque
je me vois et je m'entends parler et
immédiatement ce dont je me rends compte
c'est que ce jour là quand je prends la
parole ce n'est pas moi qui parle
ces initiations ramonet alors je sais
pas si vous connaissez il n'y a selon
ramonet il était le rédacteur en chef de
ce journal de 1991 à 2008 et donc à
force de le lire il prenait la plume
régulièrement dans ce journal
eh bien je n'avais pas exercer ma propre
pensée non au contraire j'avais
uniquement recracher les mots d'ignacio
alors à cet instant précis
ma relation privilégiée avec ignace you
a été rompu j'ai décidé de laisser
tomber et de me réfugier dans la
diversité de la presse figaro archives
les échos parlent à l'huma libe le point
enfin bref une multitude de journaux de
sources d'information je pioche est
partout et je continue à le faire parce
que ce jour-là je m'étais finalement
enfermé dans mon propre algorithme
intérieur ça a été la première leçon
pour moi une claque une prise de
conscience un esprit critique
ce n'est pas une accumulation de savoirs
la culture générale ce n'est pas que ça
elle devient intelligence lorsque les
savoirs sont confrontés sont critiqués
alors j'ai décidé de me forger vraiment
cet esprit critique
en allant à la rencontre d'autres
visions du monde il fallait confrontés
et puis au fur et à mesure nous sommes
maintenant au début de ce siècle
ce qui à muret pour moi ce sont les
différents ingrédients dont j'avais
besoin pour nourrir cet esprit critique
parce que mon prof avez raison ce jour
là lorsqu'il a dit qu'il fallait muscler
j'ai bien aimé ce l'emploi de ce verbe
parce que aujourd'hui encore je
considère que l'esprit critique est un
muscle qu'il faut nourrir qu'il faut
entraîner pour qu'il soit vivace et
vivifiant ces ingrédients pour le
nourrir c'est l'étonnement le dialogue
le doute la curiosité une pointe
d'humour et du temps aussi
et lorsque l'on mélange ses différents
ingrédients pour moi à cet esprit
critique qui à la fois vivifier
vivifiant c'est vraiment une liberté que
l'on gagne
cette quête d'esprit critique c'est
aussi une quête de liberté
l'étonnement d'abord alors je sais pas
si vous avez vu le film
itinéraire d'un enfant gâté c'est un
film que j'aime beaucoup
peut-être que vous visualisez la scène
où jean paul belmondo et saïd enseigné à
richard anconina à ne pas être étonné
par cette scène elle est très drôle
on est vraiment dans le comble des lots
de l'étonnement on est même dans le
registre de la farce
est ce que j'aime dans ce moment c'est
cet étonnement parce que je considère
que garder cette capacité à s'étonner du
monde
et bien finalement c'est comme l'enfant
qui après l'étonnement la surprise se
demande pourquoi c'est garder une
capacité à poser cette question pourquoi
et lorsque l'on pose cette question on
cherche à apprendre à découvrir et donc
à aller au delà de ses propres
connaissances
l'étonnement c'est le premier ingrédient
pour moi de cet esprit critique pour
aussi ne pas tomber dans le c'est comme
ça vous savez c'est comme ça donc on n'y
peut rien on accepte et on ne réfléchit
pas on ne se pose pas de questions on ne
remet pas en jeu le dialogue ensuite
alors moi je suis assez solitaire même
assez timide
vous imaginez comme vous m'impressionnez
et ce dialogue parfois il peut être
intérieur mais ce dialogue
évidemment
il se nourrit de l'autre il faut une
autre idée qui vient en contrepoint de
ce que l'on pense il faut un autre
regard
il faut un autre de chair et de sang
comme comme vous ce soir pour commencer
à instaurer ce dialogue le dialogue et
puis le doute le je doute donc je suis
parce que douter pour moi c'est une
vertu
alors évidemment il y a des certitudes
mais aux certitudes je préfère vraiment
le doute qui permet de ré de remettre en
question ce que l'on voit ce que l'on
entend mais aussi de se remettre en
question soient les certitudes pour moi
elle présente un risque lorsque l'on est
figé sur ses certitudes on assène des
vérités on donne la leçon et finalement
on ne voit que ce qui caresse ses
certitudes on entend que ce qui les
bears et en autorise que ce qui les a
fait remis et j'ai envie de douter pour
justement me mettre peut-être un peu en
danger mais surtout continuer à
apprendre
après le doute la curiosité aussi qui a
pu dire un jour que la curiosité est un
vilain défaut
quelle absurdité non être curieux de
l'autre est avancé et entrer en dialogue
être curieux du monde donc regarder ce
monde s'en étonner et ensuite à prendre
être curieux et donc ne pas avoir peur
de ce que l'on ne connaît pas de ce que
ce qui ne nous ressemble pas cette
curiosité pour moi est vraiment
l'ingrédient essentiel pour nourrir mon
esprit critique pour le nourrir il ya
également un peu d'humour c'est bien
l'humour il y à l'humour tourné vers les
autres rigoler sourire et puis aussi il
est à l'humour que l'on tourne vers soi
on pourrait parler d'auto dérision
parce que si l'on sait rire de soi eh
bien on se rend compte que ne pas se
prendre trop au sérieux
ça aide à douter
ça aide aussi à s'étonner de ce que l'on
voit de ce que l'on entend alors douté
évidemment
ce n'est pas se mettre ce n'est pas
perdre le fil de sa pensée
cet humour tourner vers soi il nous
nourrit il nous aide justement à se
remettre en question et puis il ya le
temps le temps c'est que c'est
extrêmement important alors je vais vous
faire une petite citation que j'ai
cherché pour l'occasion donc ce n'est
pas un mantra que je me répète jour
après jour
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que je les
noter j'avais peur de l'apprendre par
coeur
quand l'avenir est une jungle de points
d'interrogation c'est avec la machette
de l'humour et de l'esprit critique
qu'il faut se frayer un chemin d'un
certain grégoire lacroix
ce que j'aime dans cette phrase c'est
qu'il y à l'avenir et ces incertitudes
évidemment il y à l'humour et l'esprit
critique
toutes ces choses qui vont si bien
ensemble
aujourd'hui exercer son esprit critique
au présent ça peut être franchement
compliqué parce que nous sommes dans une
époque où à coups de réseaux sociaux
alors je vous avoue je m'y adonne bien
largement et bien volontiers mais cette
époque nous pousse à vivre dans
l'immédiateté à vivre dans la réaction
une actualité balaye l'autre qui est
ensuite bousculé par le buzz du jour
vous voyez très bien de quoi je veux
parler fait immédiate et cette urgence
qui dicte sa loi
eh bien ça nous empêche de poser notre
réflexion dans le temps et moi mon
esprit critique en tout cas il a besoin
de temps il se construit sur le socle du
temps et ce temps j'ai décidé un jour eh
bien justement ii d'anjou et de ce temps
et de convoquer le futur pour m'aider à
mieux regarder le présent à mieux
l'interrogé alors pour ce faire j'ai
créé un podcast je sais pas si vous
connaissez ce type de format audio qu'on
écoute sur une application un smartphone
un ordinateur bref sur le web et dans ce
podcast
je convoque le futur avec mes invités
alors il ne s'agit pas de tomber dans la
nostalgie du futur vous savez les
voitures volantes qu'on a espéré à un
moment où les hologrammes qui pourrait
s'ouvrir au creux de notre pomme
pourparlers avec le des gens qui vivent
sur une autre planète non c'est pas ça
ce que je souhaite c'est vraiment donné
l'opportunité d'imaginer d'autres
possibles tout à l'heure je disais
souvent se résumant c'est comme ça on
peut pas faire autrement
et bien si par l'imaginaire on arrive à
imaginer d'autres possibles et bien d'un
coup je suis persuadé que cela nous aide
à regarder le présent avec plus de
lucidité plus d'acuité
alors évidemment les auteurs de
science-fiction de fond ça depuis bien
longtemps il invente des mondes par le
biais de leur imaginaire de la
littérature qu'il propose et là moi le
pari que je fais avec cet espace qui
contractent le temps c'est d'interroger
des personnes comme vous comme moi comme
nous parce que il n'ya pas que les
propre et prospectiviste ni les auteurs
qu'ils peuvent imaginer ce futur nous en
avons tous la capacité et à chaque fois
évidemment c'est un détour de l'esprit
il ne s'agit pas de chercher une
quelconque vérité et d'ailleurs vous le
savez comme moi la vérité est ailleurs
donc on imagine des futurs possibles et
de là on interroge le présent alors je
vais vous donner quelques exemples de
thèmes que nous avons interrogés je
parle de l'afrique y tient un continent
qui m'est très cher l'afrique
on l'a beaucoup regardé à une époque
avec un regard paternaliste
c'est le continent de l'aide au
développement c'est le continent de la
misère et puis aujourd'hui on a un autre
regard c'est le continent de la
croissance à deux chiffres le continent
de l'avenir de l'europe de la france
et puis dans le podcast avec un
historien qui était mon invité il me
disait et bien tiens si on imaginait
l'idée un peu folle que le continent
africain devenez invisible
on ne voyait plus ce n'est plus une
terre qui devient la pas d'autres
continents où d'autres puissances
économiques et de la en interrogeant
cette invisibilité du continent vient on
s'est posé des questions sur comment en
étant autonome des tâches et finalement
du reste du monde
le continent pourrait construire des
stratégies pad africaine de
développement et là on remet en cause un
c'est comme ça du présent auxquelles
nous sommes soumis aujourd'hui le
féminisme ça aussi c'est un sujet qui
qui est très cher pour moi avec une
féministe engagée
c'est un peu un pléonasme on a imaginé
une france en 2050 ou sur tous les
frontons serait écrit liberté égalité
sororité ça peut paraître un peu fou
mais peut-être pas tant que ça et en
tout cas ça nous a permis de nous
interroger sur les trajectoires et de
bousculer le patriarcat qui règne encore
largement aujourd'hui est de faire et de
d'imaginer comment faire advenir les
changements qui nous paraissent
nécessaires avec un chercheur en
algorithmes et on s'est imaginé un monde
en 2050 ou les algorithmes qui sont des
choix qui sont des choix serait soumis
au débat démocratique
et il ne serait pas accaparé par des
sphères privées des entreprises où
quelques décideurs et ça permet de
remettre en cause tout notre rapport à
ces nouveaux outils à cette intelligence
plus ou moins artificiel qui viendraient
dicter nos vies de parcours sup à plein
d'autres champs du quotidien sur les
solidarités environnementale on a
également imaginé un monde avec un
écologue où la solidarité
environnementale serait un principe
premier de notre monde
et d'un coup cet imaginaire nous paraît
nous permet d'interroger le rapport de
domination 7 anthropocène ou la toute
puissance de l'humain nuit à la faune et
à la flore on en entend de plus en plus
parler aujourd'hui
alors je pourrai vous faire une liste
très longue il ya eu 71 voyage vers le
futur qui ont été réalisés en deux ans
et tous ces voyages affermissent mon
esprit critique parce qu'ils me
permettent de me poser de nouvelles
questions sur des sujets que parfois moi
même je croyais ne pas pouvoir remettre
en cause alors que si tous les sujets de
notre société peut être peuvent être
questionné parfois le futur nous aide à
nous autoriser ces réflexions
alors ces différents éléments
l'humour le futur le temps
l'étonnement le doute le dialogue la
curiosité ce sont des ingrédients tout
simple vous me direz
mais parfois c'est dans la simplicité
que l'on peut retrouver cette liberté
cette liberté
j'ai le sentiment de la gagner par cette
démarche de d'étirement et également de
musculation de cet esprit critique
alors je vous invite à peut-être vous
poser la question quand et j'étais
étonné pour la dernière fois quand
est-ce que j'ai douté pour la dernière
fois
quand est-ce que j'ai une curiosité
active vers l'autre faire un inconnu et
toutes ces questions là permettent de se
dire eh bien moi aussi je peux
facilement muscler cet esprit critique
il y a également cela de beau dans cette
boussole qui me guide profondément
quasiment au quotidien c'est que cette
démarche elle n'a pas de diplôme elle
n'a pas de couleur de peau
elle n'a pas de sexe tous ces
ingrédients on les a chacun on nous il
suffit d'un peu de d'exercice un fait
aussi un choix de vie mais on a tous à
notre portée les outils pour muscler au
quotidien et continuer à avancer autour
de cet esprit critique qui est si
précieux alors pour conclure parce que
le temps passe très vite
j'ai envie de finir par trois mots trois
mots qui me sont extrêmement chères à
voir à la différence de cette citation
je vous donnais tout à l'heure que j'ai
cherché quasiment juste avant de venir
trois mots qui portent en eux tout ce
que je fais au tour de cet esprit
critique toute cette quête existentielle
autour de cette démarche
ces trois mots c'est tout simplement
soyons toujours curieux